the iphone 14 pro max is here and it has
come to challenge the current flagship
of smartphones the s22 ultra from
samsung now this is a phone that is
loved by a lot of reviewers including
ourselves because obviously it looks
very nice and it has great performance
in all aspects especially the cameras
but that is where apple has come with
some huge camera changes this year to
challenge it so in this video i'm going
to compare everything between these two
phones the speakers the performance the
displays the display quality battery
life and much more so let's get right
into it now the nice thing about the s22
ultra right now is that it is discounted
and you can find it on amazon right now
for 10.50 that's fully unlocked compared
to the 14 pro max which is eleven
hundred dollars at least in the us so
they're very similarly priced but the
crazy thing is that you can even find
the s22 ultra refurbished as low as
under 700 dollars so that's a great deal
if you have t-mobile now as far as the
finish i went with the new space black
for the 14 pro max which honestly isn't
that different compared to the previous
graphite at least on the back glass but
i love how the new camera rings and the
sides are just fully black so i'm really
liking that new design especially the
new design for the flash module but
looking over at the s22 ultra i love
this new camera bump design that they
implemented it looks so much better than
that previous chunky block that they had
especially since they have four cameras
on the back and i'll talk about that in
just a minute but in terms of design
they both look great now in terms of
comfort they are a little bit different
because the iphone has these flat sides
and the s22 ultra kind of wraps around
in a rounded design which feels really
comfy however the corners are just fully
boxed off
so that could kind of dig into your palm
but i do like how they have all of the
buttons on one side so you can see the
volume right here and the power button
which is lower on the s22 compared to a
little bit higher on the iphone but one
thing that really sucks for us iphone
users is that apple got rid of the sim
slot so that really sucks for people who
are traveling and they can't easily
switch out a physical sim compared to
the s22 ultra which still has that sim
slot and you can even put up to two
sim slots in some areas now as far as
the thickness of both of these phones
the samsung is actually a little bit
thicker in terms of the body the metal
slab but because the iphones have
massive camera bumps that stick out so
much it actually is thicker if you're
looking at just the camera bumps now as
far as battery life the samsung does
have a larger battery at least
physically but in terms of the actual
battery life the iphone actually wins
out because of the better software
optimization but surprisingly even
though the iphone has a smaller battery
it's actually heavier than the s22 ultra
now one thing that really disappoints me
about the iphone 14 pro max is that it
still has a lightning port no they have
not switched over to usbc which of
course the s22 ultra has and not only
that but it's still lightning 2.0 with
slower speeds even though it has a 48
megapixel camera now before i get into
all of the massive display differences
like the always-on display that you see
right here i do want to talk about my
favorite mac safe wallet of all time
which has a built-in stand and grip that
you can use in many different angles now
this of course is our partner moth's
snap-on wallet and stand which comes in
four different colors that perfectly
match the new iphone 14 pro colors their
purple wallet matches the new deep
purple iphone 14 pro color they've got
the beach white wallet to match the gold
iphone 14 pro the misti cove wallet
matches the silver model and the dark
gray or black wallets match the space
black on the iphone 14 pro but if you
want to mix it up moft also has 15
colors to choose from now what i
personally recommend is getting the moft
max safe case because the magnetic
strength basically becomes two times
stronger it is incredibly strong not
only for the moft wallet stand but also
for all your other mac safe accessories
and i also like how the white case kind
of offsets the colors of the iphone that
you can see through the transparent
window and the matching wallet and maft
also has adhesive versions of the wallet
for non-max iphones like the s22 ultra
so check them out using the links in the
description below now getting back to
the always-on displays finally apple has
one after so many years of not having
one and that's because it runs at only
one hertz that means every second the
display refreshes just one time which
makes it very efficient now the s22
ultra unfortunately there are reports
that it only goes down to 24 hertz even
in always-on display mode which is
wasting battery life and impressively
the always-on display on the iphone is
really bright like some people complain
that it's too bright but the main
difference is that you can actually see
your wallpaper
on the iphone at all times it just dims
down and gets dark but it keeps those
colors whereas on the s22 ultra you just
have an all black display now the iphone
is limited to just four customizable
widgets which you can also put the
battery life indicator just like the s22
ultra has the better life on the bottom
which is very convenient as well as a
long list of widgets and i also like how
they have the ultrasonic fingerprint
logo right here so you can just unlock
it just like that but something new with
the iphone this year is that you can
swipe from the always on display to
unlock it which i'm very happy because
you used to have to tap to wake it up
and then swipe so it's all in one motion
just like on the s22 ultra now
personally i love face id more than the
ultrasonic scanner because it works kind
of transparently and it is very secure
in terms of facial recognition and one
thing i really love is that apple
implemented the face id into the new
dynamic island so whenever you unlock
face id or authenticate it all happens
up there with the nice animation now on
the flip side the s22 ultra has a tiny
little camera hole which is so clean and
it definitely gets in the way a lot less
than the iphone does and some people
online have also been showing the
dynamic island getting in the way of two
by one video which is so annoying and i
know that apple said that they reduced
the bezel size on the iphone but it's
still just so much thicker than the
really thin and nice bezels on the s22
ultra but i am happy that apple
significantly slimmed down the earpiece
speaker so you can almost just barely
notice it just like it is on the s22
ultra and in terms of the actual display
quality the samsung has a slightly
larger display with higher ppi and in
terms of the peak brightness indoors
they're basically the same if you max
them out however if you go outside you
can see that the iphone's higher 2 000
nits of peak brightness definitely help
you see the display now this is very
interesting the iphone's rated up to
1600 nits while watching hdr
but the s22 ultra is actually brighter
in this case so i don't know what's
going on why it's not going up to the
full 1600 but honestly the s22 ultra
looks better for hdr video here and in
this case with them side by side i
definitely noticed a difference in the
bezels being thinner on the s22 ultra
and that single hole punch camera barely
intruding on the video compared to the
dynamic island so basically for watching
video the s22 ultra is the winner but
what about the speaker quality because
we just did our 14 pro max versus 13 pro
max full comparison which you should
definitely watch if you haven't already
and we noticed that the speakers had a
major improvement so let's compare them
to the s22 ultra
[Music]
um yes it's the same song again and wow
that was a crazy comparison because the
s22 ultra used to be better than the
iphone 13 pro max but this 14 just went
crazy in terms of the sound quality and
the volume so it's louder the separation
of frequencies is much better in terms
of the sound stage so you can actually
hear the high end kind of cut away from
the mids whereas the s22 ultra kind of
clashes everything together
it doesn't do a good job of separating
the different instruments and sounds and
i also hear a lot more volume from the
bottom speaker whereas the iphone is
perfectly balanced between the earpiece
and the bottom so i'm so impressed with
the iphone this year now before i get
into the performance testing i do want
to show off something that's totally
unique to the s22 ultra something that
the iphone doesn't offer and that is of
course the s pen which is built into the
s22 ultra i love that it's always there
when you need it and of course you can
use it like a stylus for notes signing
documents anything you want now getting
into performance the first test we're
gonna do is a geekbench 5 cpu test but
first i've got to talk about the
processor differences because the iphone
14 pro max has the new a16 bionic chip
while the s22 ultra has the snapdragon 8
gen 1. now in terms of ram the iphone is
still unfortunately with only 6 gigs of
faster lp ddr 5 memory while the s22
ultra gets between 8 and 12 gigs
depending on your storage and this model
actually has the 12 gigs so double the
ram and let's run this test and would
you look at that difference apple just
keeps going further and further ahead
they're not letting anybody catch up in
terms of the single core we're getting
as much as 18
73 that's 50 faster than the s22 ultra
and for multi-core
64
faster i can't believe they have this
big of a lead and with that said let's
also run the graphics test with gfx
bench and the 1440p aztec ruins off
screen now while this is running i also
want to talk about gaming because apple
did say they improved the thermal system
but in our previous video comparing the
14 pro max with the 13 pro max it's
still dimmed now not as much but it
still did whereas the s22 ultra it does
an excellent job keeping the display at
the brightness that you set it to in
terms of gaming and other tasks and
while we wait for the results i do want
to mention a couple of other spec
differences the iphone has a new
bluetooth 5.3 compared to 5.2 on the
samsung and the water resistance is four
times better because it has ip68 at up
to six meters compared to only 1.5 on
the samsung and there you go we have a
result and it looks like the iphone gets
34 percent more fps than the s22 ultra
and now let's talk about the camera
differences the iphone has a new 12
megapixel camera on the front compared
to 40 on the s22 ultra and then on the
back they're very similar except that
the samsung has a physical 10x optical
zoom lens which the iphone doesn't
because it's limited to 3x and it has
108 megapixels for the main compared to
the brand new 48 megapixel main on the
iphone now we're gonna be taking these
phones over the weekend and taking a
bunch of shots i'm gonna put them
together and i'm gonna have max and
angelica look at them blind not knowing
which photo was taken with which phone
and i'm also gonna use the z fold for so
that is going to be a must watch if
you're interested in the camera
differences and now with all that said
and compared let's get to my final
conclusion now the iphone has a lot of
upgrades and advantages that we now have
over the s22 ultra that i really love
especially that peak brightness and the
speaker difference and of course the
performance but the s22 ultra also has
some ways that it still beats out the
iphone and it's nice that you can get it
for quite a bit cheaper than the iphone
but the final verdict that is gonna
leave it up to which one wins is gonna
be that unbiased camera comparison so if
you're interested definitely subscribe
by clicking the circle above so you
don't miss out on that video and watch
our other videos right over there
including the 14 pro max versus 13 pro
max comparison thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you